um yeah so the organization that i i
co-founded with my co-founder rachel
chung was strut safe we were
founded um back in back in march after
unfortunately the death of sarah everard
in that aftermath
um because i think we
along with so many people across the uk
felt this
palpable frustration and anger that
women can't seem to do something as
simple as walk home without risk of
harassment attack murder
and so we wanted to put something
tangible in place to try and support
people across the country
um and it started with just walking home
put walking people home in edinburgh
which is where we're based
and then we expanded across the uk as a
phone-only service um so if you're
walking home and you feel unsafe and
we're not just there for women we're
there for anybody who wants to call us
but it is primarily women who get in
touch with us
um
and we'll stay on the phone with you and
we'll attempt to reassure you and we'll
be someone there so you don't feel so
alone and if something happens where
contact there
um as well
but one wonders how even with a service
like that you could possibly have
envisaged a police officer stopping
somebody at nine o'clock at night not
that late
um and saying i want to arrest you
because you've broken covet rules
handcuffing her behind her back
putting her in a vehicle driving her for
two hours she the the terror that she
must have felt in that time
raping her in a vehicle and then killing
her with his police belt
unbelievable i know
it's it's it's so gruesome and so
heartbreaking and i think
aside from the anger i think we all feel
like you say it's just such
a heartbreaking thing to reflect on
and i don't know i'm sure you've read
the the statement from from sarah's
mother
um in which she reiterates some of these
same things
but it's it's unfortunately isn't a it
is an abuse of power and i think
um
unfortunately there is there are so
people don't feel safe with these
authorities because
um
like you said it was a police officer
that stopped her that abused
abused you know his power as a police
officer and i think
there's so
i think we've been reflecting so much
about how it could have been any one of
us and the fact is that it was one of us
every time that the 101 women who have
died at the hands of male violence since
the death of sarah everard
who perhaps we haven't had that same
energy and and outrage and uproar for
it was it was one of us every time and
in in conditions as as as gruesome and
as tragic as hers and that's not to take
away from what happened to sarah of
course but
um it really makes you reflect and as an
organization we're try we're trying to
be there for as many people as we can
um
but obviously uh our resources are
limited compared to an institution like
the government
um and i think there needs to be
fundamental institutional change to
protect women to protect marginalized
groups
um because unfortunately this this will
keep happening and i think there's a
societal problem as well in the way that
men see women and often the way in which
women's lives of you know viewed as
expandable
um
and and i think we we need to have a lot
of
it needs to do a lot of work to reform
the way in which women are viewed in
society from a young age
sure there are apps available of course
that uh can can basically walk you home
a call center uh as a live app on on
your phone you can call people if you
need them those are coming on stream all
the time but what's your advice to to
women particularly who who are listening
this morning about how to try to keep
that little bit safer when they're
potentially walking home or even getting
out of their car at night on their own
i think it's so difficult to offer that
advice because
so many women live in the knowledge that
whatever precautions you might take
whether it's
calling a friend whether it's calling
strength safe whether it's
keeping your keys between your fingers
whether it's picking a different route
whether it's only only a short walk you
know only five minutes across the park
which was the walk that sabine nessa
took and unfortunately didn't survive
um
whatever advice i might offer
whatever advice any of us might offer
i don't think it's enough because
sometimes all it's doing
is saying make sure
make sure he attacks the other girl
make sure it's not me
and whatever precaution you might take
like you say at 9pm in the evening it's
not
it's not so late that nobody's about
is it going to be enough
and i don't say that
to put any responsibility on women
i say that to put the responsibility on
the people who attack and kill these
women
because it's their responsibility and
women should never ever be made
responsible for the actions that are
committed against them